[Música]
la guerra en ucrania entró en su cuarta
semana mientras siguen los esfuerzos
diplomáticos para detenerla el ejército
ruso se ensaña especialmente contra los
civiles la organización de naciones
unidas o robe oro la muerte de más de
700 personas tenemos información desde
quién
la organización mundial de la salud
cifró en 43 los ataques de las fuerzas
rusas a centros sanitarios de ucrania
mientras decenas de familias se refugian
en hospitales materno-infantiles cada
vez que suenan las alarmas antiaéreas
vamos a poder saberlo con nuestra
enviada especial
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
afirmó que vladimir putin es un dictador
asesino después de acusarlo de crímenes
de guerra por los constantes ataques
sobre la población civil según by them
putin está librando una guerra inmoral
contra el pueblo de ucrania
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos la guerra rusa en ucrania
entró en su cuarta semana y los
esfuerzos diplomáticos siguen sin dar
fruto la onu ha podido corroborar la
muerte de 726 civiles entre ellos 52
niños y mil 174 heridos sin embargo el
avance de las tropas rusas está
estancado según el ministerio de defensa
del reino unido- nuestra enviada
especial a ucrania irene sabio nos
resumía previamente el día 22 de la
invasión las negociaciones para un alto
el fuego entre rusia y ucrania continúan
y también empiezan a despejarse algunas
dudas como por ejemplo que esta
discusión no incluye las regiones
prorrusas del donbass esto significa que
según la versión ucraniana se está
debatiendo únicamente sobre la retirada
de las tropas rusas regulares que han
sido desplegadas después del 24 de
febrero que es cuando inició la invasión
de rusia en ucrania
en el terreno la guerra continúa y se
está enseñando en particular con los
civiles esta mañana nos hemos despertado
con ataques en los suburbios de la
capital de ucrania kiev y también nos
han llegado en formaciones durante la
jornada de otros bombardeos ocurridos en
mariupol en el sur y en hardcover
también continúa el drama humanitario de
los desplazados lo una última hora es
que el gobierno de república checa ha
dicho que no puede recibir a más
refugiados ucranianos ante el gran
número de personas que han cruzado su
frontera en las últimas semanas y
mientras centros clínicos son destruidos
en la ciudad de odessa decenas de
familias se refugian en el hospital
materno-infantil cada vez que suenan las
alarmas antiaéreas ellos se rehúsan a
abandonar ese histórico puerto en el mar
negro la historia es de nuestra enviada
especial catalina gómez ángel
estamos en el hospital infantil de
odessa donde se ha habilitado este
subterráneo para cuidar a los niños que
atienden ellos la mayoría de ellos son
neonatos a los que traen aquí o niños
que han sufrido alguna cirugía ha sido
interesante ver especialmente la cara de
las madres o de sus padres que
constantemente no solamente pasan los
días y las noches con estos niños en el
hospital toda la preocupación de que
estos niños estén aquí durante una
guerra sino toda la situación que tiene
que venir pasar aquí horas esperar a que
la alarma se acabe lo que crea muchísima
más ansiedad hablábamos con varias de
estas familias algunas de ellas no se
quieren ir de odessa porque no tienen
las circunstancias o no quieren
abandonar al padre o son familias
numerosas sin embargo obviamente toda
esta preocupación como hablábamos se
hace aún mayor cuando estos niños están
enfermos y hay que pasar horas y horas
en un hospital aunque también hay que
decir que esté subterráneo está mejor
equipado y está más protegido que otros
lugares de la ciudad porque a diferencia
de ciudades como en kif otras grandes
ciudades de ucrania aquí en odessa no
hay tan buenos subterráneos dicen que no
están tan bien equipados así que muchas
de las población se queda en sus casas
cuando suenan las alarmas
rusia no logró apoyo en nueva york para
su resolución en el consejo de seguridad
de la onu la delegación de moscú canceló
el voto de su documento que buscaba que
se afirmara que occidente tiene una
posición anti rusa luego de no contar
con el apoyo de china ni de india
mientras tanto el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski habló ante el
parlamento alemán a través de una
videoconferencia y criticó a alemania
por la creación del oleoducto north
stream 2 aseguró que intereses
económicos contribuyeron a la creación
de un nuevo muro haciendo referencia al
muro de berlín
el actor un ex actor y presidente de
estados unidos ronald reagan dijo una
vez en berlín señor gorbachov derribe
este muro y yo le digo eso mismo a usted
apreciado canciller souls destruyan este
muro dele a alemania el liderazgo que
alemania merece para que su descendencia
esté orgullosa de usted apoyen la
libertad apoyen a ucrania detengan esta
guerra ayúdennos a parar esta guerra
larga vida a ucrania ok y el presidente
estadounidense joe biden dijo que su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin era un
dictador asesino después de acusarlo de
crímenes de guerra por los constantes
ataques sobre la población civil en
ucrania andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
baiden con sus palabras escala la
atención diplomática en medio de un
almuerzo para celebrar el día de san
patricio el presidente aprovechó para
dar su opinión sobre su homólogo
vladimir putin nadie harman
y ahora tienes a irlanda y el reino
unido- y ya sabes a la repubblica unidas
contra un dictador asesino un puro matón
que está librando una guerra inmoral
contra el pueblo de ucrania
irlanda que ahora hace parte del consejo
de seguridad de la onu apoya a estados
unidos la unión europea reino unido y
otros países en el bloqueo económico
contra rusia el miércoles vaivén había
dicho que putin era un criminal de
guerra
de palabras respaldadas por su
secretario de estado y hace de ayer el
presidente de bailén dijo que en su
opinión se han cometido crímenes de
guerra en ucrania por eso ni
personalmente estoy de acuerdo en atacar
intencionalmente a civiles es un crimen
de guerra después de toda la destrucción
de las últimas tres semanas me resulta
difícil concluir que los rusos estén
haciendo lo contrario hawas el kremlin
respondió a las fuertes acusaciones
estas declaraciones del señor bailen
como dije ayer son absolutamente
inaceptables impropias imperdonables
y lo que es más importante creo que
tales comentarios no pueden ser hechos
por un jefe de estado que ha estado
bombardeando a la gente en todo el mundo
durante años
las sanciones de occidentales sobre
moscú han puesto contra las cuerdas la
economía rusa el presidente putin quien
parece minimizar las habló sobre el
impacto que tienen sobre la región de
crimea y aseguró que son una oportunidad
para que las empresas rusas trabajen en
la península en la ciudad de ocha que
iba al sur de ucrania se están llevando
a cabo los funerales de los soldados
caídos en la guerra ochoa que fue uno de
los primeros objetivos de rusia cuando
invadió ucrania hace ya tres semanas
aunque los bombardeos en esta ciudad se
siguen produciendo a diario no son tan
intensos como en los primeros días de la
guerra y ahora las familias pueden
sepultar a sus soldados caídos
tres semanas después de la invasión rusa
ucrania los primeros soldados caídos en
noche aquí son finalmente enterrados en
esta ciudad situada en la costa del mar
negro 24 soldados perdieron la vida en
el primer día de guerra algunos de sus
cuerpos aún no han sido recuperados se
tardó varios días en identificar al hijo
de anatoly basiliensis que murió una
semana después del inicio la guerra
cuando cuatro cohetes derribaron su
helicóptero
también bajaron a los mismos bajos
luche hoy enterrado a mi amado hijo no
habrá perdón para los caps mientras
sirva en el ejército los destruiré
nadie nuevamente
aunque los bombardeos se han reducido en
8 a 15 en comparación con los primeros
días de la invasión los ataques siguen
produciéndose aquí a diario el trauma de
la ciudad es palpable las calles están
desiertas y decenas de civiles son
evacuados cada día en autobús los que se
quedan rezan por un alto el fuego
aún así esperamos las negociaciones que
están en marcha esto es lo principal que
esperamos porque sin ello creo que la
paz no es posible a corto plazo no es la
primera vez que los soldados de ocho
aquí pagan el precio máximo de la guerra
en el centro de la ciudad se encuentra
un monumento que rinde homenaje a
decenas de soldados de la ciudad
asesinados en el donbass desde que
comenzaron los combates allí en 2014 con
estas historias personales consecuencias
de la guerra en ucrania despedimos este
repaso a la información internacional y
a ustedes les invitamos a que sigan
conectados con nosotros en france24 y
les recordamos que pueden ampliar toda
esta información en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
[Música]